route de chis et en touraine garde
encore les stigmates des pluies
diluviennes qui ont touché la commune
comme vous le voyez sur ces images
amateurs
hier en milieu d'après midi il aura
suffi de quelques minutes pour inonder
veut caves et garages et aujourd'hui
chacun se mobilise
chez mathias l'heure est au grand
nettoyage c'est descendu du coteau sa
nettoyer les champs les chemins
et puis comme nous sommes j'irai au
point le plus bas de la du lieu-dit
bonne village traité entré chez nous un
peu plus haut vous de l'enfer cette
habitante a elle aussi craint le déluge
donc là on a coupé l'électricité puisque
je pense que ça peut se voir 1 l'ol est
monté jusqu'à ce niveau là c'est ses
montées de plusieurs dizaines de
centimètres
juste le temps de sauver une ou deux
affaires de se protéger sachant qu'on
peut difficilement circuler dans les
petites rues puisque ça devient tour en
ciel donc nous on avait installé une
ligne de vie pour passer à de notre
maison aux maisons un petit peu plus
loin tu réduis le près du lavoir près de
100 mm de précipitations seraient tombés
en moins de deux heures
selon de premières estimations causant
aussi des dégâts de voirie et brisant
des canalisations
on est en train de vider en fait un
regard de visites qui rempli de sable de
cailloux donc pour pouvoir dégager tout
le tout le réseau qui est plein un petit
peu plus loin qui se déverse
malheureusement chez les personnes la
sécurité laisse et déjà qu'ils sont
dangereux déjà et puis après on va
réparer au fur et à mesure de faire des
devis on va c'est d'aller assez vite
maintenant prochaine étape pour les
victimes
la venue des premiers experts pour la
commune une demande de reconnaissance
d'état de catastrophe naturelle